I'm really interested in these things in
our age which are basically impossible
demands the most obvious one is that I
write about is the insistence that
there's a versus insistence that goes
you have to understand me and
simultaneously says you will never
understand me yeah the same person can
do both of those yeah all the time and
we have that everywhere in our side now
there are other work things of just
impossible demands for instance I say at
one point I sight a ridiculous person
who complains on the BBC that they are
often ridiculed in public and that's not
nice but I point out if you're
ridiculous you will be ridiculed hey you
can't escape it other than by not being
ridiculous and my favorite impossible
demand is the one that you just hit on
there which is the the demand that is
currently just very uncomfortably in the
culture in relation to the relations
between the sexes which is yeah women
women are allowed to be as sexual as
they want as sexy as they want but must
not be sexualized and this as I point
out is not possible now does this mean
that men can do whatever they want
obviously not obviously not and you see
this is one of the conversations that's
so hard to have because somebody always
leaps and go oh I suppose you're just a
vision Blaine wait you know oh is it so
you think women should be raped no there
are gradations between total chastity
and rape you know that's how we're here
[Laughter]
otherwise we wouldn't have Skype we
wouldn't have you we wouldn't have many
nice people watching just Chestatee
but it's a sort of it's a sort of
dementing you know we don't allow
ourselves to have this conversation at
my point is none of this means that men
can do what they want but if a woman is
entering the sex
by being highly sexualized that you know
I'm talking about the means I give them
Nicki Minaj example is because it's it's
so overtly sexual and and I particularly
interested in this video of anaconda I
belly where the audible version of my
book I read myself and it means that I
really have to read the lyrics already
put it into a video on YouTube and cut
the music over-the-top yeah I only do
whoever that is whoever that is I salute
you also to the to the people who are
listening obviously the link to Manas
the crowds the book on Amazon will be in
there but I'm gonna put the link to the
audible version as well so that you have
to hear yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be my
party piece I can see go on do Nicki do
but no but the fascinating thing about
this this video and I just I talked it
over with a lot of straight trends and I
so what she does in anaconda is among
other things all it's all completely
sexual I mean just totally sexual just
how wiggling her butt and her friends
weeping of their parts and they
sometimes hit each others butts and they
sing about each others butts and their
own butts you get the gist and and then
in case none of this has settled in she
then has a scene where she eats the
banana
sprays her breasts with whipped cream
and licks the cream off with one of her
fingers which is also always impossible
to interpret and then there's this
really interesting last 90 seconds or so
of the video where she crawls on all
fours into a sort of darkened room
towards a very handsome fit black guy in
a chair and she just does everything in
front of him it's um you know it's not
justice it's not some people say oh it's
just like strip it's like a mask yeah
it's a it's not she's she's all over his
body this is a thing she's wrapping her
legs around him she's wiggling her bath
his face she's it's a total predatory
thing and towards the end of this
interminable scene the guy you see he's
starting to you know
and he goes eventually and touches her
slightly on the side and she whips
around and smacks his hand away and
walks out and obviously the message of
the video that Nicki Minaj is giving is
I can do all of this but don't you dare
think you can control the game and this
seems to me to be a dementing demand a
dementing claim which is apart of
anything else deeply unfair to men
because the whole problem of relations
like that is when does the game become
about that when does it but when do we
enter the sex business when are we in
that proximity and and the Nicki Minaj
thing is only if I get lead you all the
way there and give you permission all
the time all the way but if I'm just
enjoying myself in a skimpy outfit
wiggling my butt in your face etc said
oh don't you even think that you still
control the situation I control it all
the time either woman and I think that
is dementing and deeply unfair to men
and not possible it's not
[Music]
you